[Applause]
Taylor Swift diving head first into
night one of her era's tour
[Music]
welcome to the era tour
the singer made her highly anticipated
return to the stage on Friday after five
years a lot of things to catch up on
because it's been a really long time
since I've been
tour
and fans are losing their minds over
this crazy stunt
[Applause]
yeah Taylor dove into the stage which
then projected her seemingly swimming
across it and resurfacing on the other
side it was Tay's iconic way of
transitioning into the midnights era of
the show thank you from the bottom of
our hearts for wanting to be with us on
night one
and we're gonna be exploring the last 17
years of music that I've been lucky
enough
to care about
the three-hour set was broken down into
10 eras representing specific moments in
Taylor's life and career which included
lots of show-stopping outfits
[Music]
some of those handcrafted looks took
over
170 hours to make
[Music]
but the Wardrobe wasn't the only thing
sparkling watch Taylor make the whole
place Shimmer with this Bejeweled Moment
by recreating the song's viral Tick Tock
dance
[Music]
number yeah Taylor's proving she's got
eyes everywhere on social media and
nothing gets past her even joking about
the fan theory that ever more is her
least favorite album this is an album I
absolutely love despite what some of you
say on Tick Tock oh I've seen it I've
seen all of it safe to say 44 songs
later Swifty's got their money's worth
in a night they'll never forget I've
missed you so much and uh I can't even
go into how much I missed you because
there's no way to verbalize it you have
really really really overwhelmed and
trying to keep it together all night
same sailor same
foreign
[Applause]